I know you lost your mother recently and
with isolation right now I don't even
think it's right question asked is how
are you put more how are you coping what
I've been holding up pretty good that I
totally enjoyed it quarantine I was in
Oklahoma for two months I just got back
matter of fact we had I had gone back to
go back and prepare for mamas funeral
she passed away March the 14th so I went
back the 15th we had to kind of postpone
everything so I stayed there for two
months in Oklahoma was my family on the
ranch where I grew up it was wonderful
very healing how are you staying
positive in days like this for me it's
very easy to stay positive it's it's
hard to think negative when you're in a
world where people are learning how to
do things differently adjusting and
thinking about others instead of just
yourself my actions will affect others
one way or the other so think positive
stay positive and you'll help other
people to be positive now recently you
teamed up with your Arriba co-star uh
Melissa Peterman to create a video
talking about your characters on how
they are coping with isolation girl I'm
going crazy I'm hiding in the closet
right now because Brock and Henry aren't
driving me but in Hannah's kids have
been want me to play games all day long
I've played more games and you can
imagine you know how much I like games
if I'm sick of it sick of it how did the
concept come up and we'll leave you
doing more Melissa comes up with the
greatest ideas and oh heck yeah I'd do
it heartily in a heartbeat with no
anything with Melissa she's always very
creative and a lot of fun not twenty
three years ago you released a song what
if but recently you re-released a video
why now you know
[Music]
now it's more prevalent I'd say what if
we just join together and sing with one
voice reached out with just one hand
maybe we could change things
and in the video we put things that are
going on now people wearing the face
mask and having to talk through glasses
and windows to loved ones and it's it
just would it really hit home that's
today more than ever we need to join
together